so on the side of reward functions
that's uh coming up with good reward
functions seems to be the thing that we
associate with uh
general intel like human beings seem to
value the idea of developing our own
reward functions
of uh you know arriving at meaning and
so on
and yet for reinforcement learning we
often kind of specify that's the given
what's your sense of how we develop
reward you know good reward functions
yeah i think that's a very
uh complicated and very deep question
and you're completely right that
classically in reinforcement learning
this question
has kind of been treated as a non-issue
that you sort of
treat the reward as this external thing
that comes from
some other bit of your biology and you
kind of don't worry about it
and i do think that that's actually you
know a little bit of a mistake that we
should worry about it
and we can approach it in a few
different ways we can approach it for
instance
by thinking of rewards as a
communication medium we can say well how
does a person
communicate to a robot what its
objective is you can approach it also as
sort of more of an intrinsic motivation
medium you could say
can we write down kind of a general
objective that leads to
uh good capability like for example can
you write down some objectives such that
even in the absence of any other task
if you maximize that objective you'll
sort of learn useful things
this is a something that has sometimes
been called unsupervised reinforcement
learning which i think is a really
fascinating
uh area of research especially today uh
we've done a bit of work on that
recently one of the things we've studied
is whether
uh we can have some notion of uh
of unsupervised reinforcement learning
by means of
um you know information theoretical
quantities like for instance minimizing
a bayesian measure of surprise this is
an idea that was
uh you know pioneered actually in the
computational neuroscience community by
folks like
carl fristen and we've done some work
recently that shows that you can
actually learn pretty interesting
skills by essentially behaving in a way
that
that allows you to make accurate
predictions about the world
it seems a little circular like do the
things that will lead to you getting the
right answer
uh for for prediction but you can you
know
by doing this you can sort of discover
stable niches in the world you can
discover that
if you're playing tetris then correctly
uh you know clearing the rows will let
you play tetris for longer and keep the
board nice and clean which
sort of satisfies some desire for order
in the world and as a result
get some degree of leverage over your
domain so we're exploring that pretty
actively
is there a role for a human notion of
curiosity
in itself being the reward sort of
discovering new things about the war
the world so one of the things that i'm
pretty interested in is actually whether
um discovering new things uh
can actually be an emergent property of
some other objective that quantifies
capability so new things for the sake of
new things
maybe is not maybe might not by itself
be the right
answer but perhaps we can figure out an
objective
for which discovering new things is
actually the natural consequence
uh that's something we're working on
right now but i don't have a clear
answer for you there yet that's still a
work in progress
you mean just it's a curious observation
to see
uh sort of creative the the
patterns of curiosity on the way to
optimize for a particular
on the way to optimize for a particular
measure of capability
is uh is there ways to understand or
[Music]
anticipate unexpected
unintended consequences of particular
reward
functions sort of uh anticipate the kind
of tr
strategies that might be developed and
try to avoid
highly detrimental strategies yeah uh
so classically this is something that
has been pretty hard in reinforcement
learning because
it's uh difficult for a designer to have
good intuition about
you know what a learning algorithm will
come up with when they give it some
objective
there are ways to mitigate that one way
to mitigate it is to actually
define an objective that says like don't
do weird stuff
you can actually quantify you can say
just like don't enter situations that
have low probability
under the distribution of states you've
seen before
it turns out that's actually one very
good way to do off-policy reinforcement
learning actually
so we can do some things like that if we
uh
slowly venture in speaking about reward
functions
into greater and greater levels of
intelligence there's uh
i mean stuart russell thinks about this
the alignment
of ai systems with us humans
so how do we ensure that agi systems
align with us humans it's a
it's kind of a reward function question
of specifying the behavior of ai systems
such that their success aligns with us
with the broader intended success
interest of human beings do you have
thoughts on this you have kind of
concerns
of where reinforcement learning fits
into this are you really focused on
the current moment of us being quite far
away and trying to solve the robotics
problem
i don't have a great answer to this but
um
you know and i do think that this is a
problem that's that's important to
figure out
for my part i'm actually a bit more
concerned about
the other side of the of this equation
that uh you know maybe
rather than unintended consequences for
uh objectives that are specified too
well i'm actually more worried
right now about intended consequences
for objectives that are not
optimized well enough which might become
a very pressing problem
when we for instance try to use these
techniques for safety critical systems
like
cars and aircraft and so on i think at
some point we'll face the issue of
objectives being optimized too well but
right now i think we're we're more
likely to face the issue of them not
being optimized well enough
but you don't think unintended
consequences can arise even when you're
far from optimality sort of like on the
path
to it oh no i think unintended
consequences can absolutely arise
uh it's just i think right now the
bottleneck for
improving reliability safety and things
like that
is more with systems that like need to
work better that need to optimize their
objectives better
you